Well I guess they don't have
the big Hollywood marketing
budgets at Comedy Central
so I got me shilling out here
on the street corner.
I don't think you can do it.
I know you know what a bad idea
is. You're in a lot of movies
that are bad ideas.
But this is a worse idea. This
is like Die Hard 4 Live Free-
whatever.
That was a bad idea.
This is a worse idea.
This is a career low.
You're the biggest movie star
in the world they should be-
Well, you're almost the biggest-
At one point you were almost the
biggest movie star in the world
and they should be treating you
better than this
Comedy Central trying
to save a few bucks.
This is bullshit.
Oh you're right.
You're right.
Does anybody watch
Comedy Central anymore?
Honestly, you could
really do better.
So, I'll see you there.
Yeah, I'm gonna be there man!
I'm your Roastmaster!
OK. Gotta go. Bye!
(car honking)
Aye! Roastmaster!
Fuck you!